hey youtubers it's Charlie this week for
my bonus video I wanted to dive a little
bit deeper into the faith of the seven
just talking about the faith militant
they're militarized order as well as the
high Sparrow this is mostly gonna be
history video but after that I'll
explain how I think the show might use
him not all the major organizations and
mercenary groups have been featured from
the books or even the last High Septon
Jonathan Pryce is the third one in the
chronology of the show so presumably
because they picked such a high-profile
actor they're going to be featuring the
church much more in season 5 if you're
just finding me for the first time
though I'm doing weekly bonus videos
until season 5 gets here be sure to
subscribe to you everything I'm even
doing a weekly giveaway that I'll
explain at the end of the video so
starting off with the faith militant
they're the militarized arm of the faith
of the seven they're made up from two
different subgroups inside the church
called the warrior sons in the poor
fellow's you can imagine how they decide
who gets to be in which order the
warrior sons are made about Knights and
other highborn people that have sworn
off their lands and titles they swear
their allegiance to the High Septon and
then they gain special armor just like
the Kingsguard and just like the
Kingsguard the most defining
characteristic is the cloak the warrior
sons wear rainbow color cloaks just like
the Kingsguard wear white cloaks
in the city watch where gold cloaks
their armors a little bit different from
the Kingsguard to its silver instead of
being gold they do have special swords
with star-shaped crystals in the pommels
stars being imagery of the seven pointed
star of the faith they have a reputation
for fanaticism that kind of makes you
think of the unsullied although they're
very very different you know they have
not been cut something about religious
armies attracting fanatics that doesn't
sound good the poor fellows on the other
side of that equation are made up of the
peasantry and women yes they do actually
allow women to fight for them they serve
as the lightly armored footmen of the
faith militant and instead of the really
nice armored weapons that the warrior
sons get they just wear whatever they
can find they don't have any official
weapon and they don't get to wear the
rainbow cloaks so the interesting thing
about these two branches of the faith
militant is that they do predate Aegon's
conquest but they haven't always existed
after Aegon the conquerer is death there
was a big conflict called the faith
militant uprising because Aegon had
openly married his two sisters the faith
of the seven viewed their children as
sinful abominations
so whenever a God's oldest son anise
took the throne the faith launched an
uprise
to remove the Targaryen sperm power
Hagen's oldest son and as the first took
the throne but he was viewed as being
very weak willed so his brother maegor
who ended up becoming maegor the cruel
took over the job of suppressing the
church maegor the cruel was only in his
half-brother he was the son of Aegon's
other sister the interesting story about
how he got the nickname maegor the cruel
was that he basically put a bounty on
the heads of all the faith milton it was
one golden dragon for the scalp of any
warrior son remember they were the
highborn knights and a silver stag for
the scalp of any poor fellow his reign
was also characterized by a whole lot of
other interesting things that we can
talk about whenever the world of Song of
Ice and Fire book is released in October
that has a whole bunch of cool stuff in
it including full family trees for the
Targaryen zand the starts mega rented up
dying under really mysterious
circumstances while sitting on the Iron
Throne like he was literally on the Iron
Throne it just slumped over dead like he
wasn't sick or anything his reign only
lasted for about six years both he and
his brother anis died when they were
about Cersei and Jamie's age mid-30s
after a maegor died and his son took the
throne at the age of 14 and immediately
offered amnesty to the faith of the
seven if they agreed to disband the two
orders of the faith militant the Acting
High Septon at the time agreed and the
conflict was ended so this was all
hundreds of years before events on the
show fun fact one of maegor wives was
named Jeyne Westerling
in the books Jeyne Westerling is also
the name of the woman Robb Stark marries
on the show they replaced that character
with Talisa maker played by Oona Chaplin
so you can see how they changed things
on the show but try to work in
references from the books Westerling to
mega which sounds a lot like make or
anyone who's worried about George R
Martin expanding a Song of Ice and Fire
to eight books instead of just seven
remember it gives him more room for
flashbacks to talk about things like
this also for anyone who's really into
the books he's planning a Targaryen
novel series that'll just be told from
the perspective of the Targaryen family
after Song of Ice and Fire is over right
now they haven't done a lot of the
flashbacks from the books usually
historical events like the faith
militant uprising just get referenced in
conversation so that might be how the
show deals with that event so remember
the High Septon essentially has complete
control over the faith militant but
where we are in current events on the
show they've still been disbanded the
character that they cast Jonathan
price to play is the current high septon
the one that's new in book four during
season two the previous high septon was
ripped apart by the mob like they
literally ripped his arm off whenever
they attacked Joffrey the next High
Septon the one that Tyrion appointed was
also murdered you might not have noticed
him but the High Septon the tyrion chose
was the one that performed his wedding
to Sansa and the one that performed
Joffrey and Margaery wedding the show
has already changed a lot so it's
unclear how they're gonna deal with the
transition from high septon number three
Tyrians High Septon to the new one the
one that Jonathan Pryce is playing high
septons are typically appointed by the
crown but Jonathan prices character was
chosen internally the faith basically
appoints its own High Septon the reason
he's nicknamed the high Sparrow like
whenever you saw that casting video is
because he's chosen from amongst a group
of the poorest members of the faith that
enter King's Landing pleading for
protection during the war of the five
kings they collectively named themselves
sparrows so they're referred to as the
sparrows thus the new High Septon
becomes the high Sparrow there was a lot
of [ __ ] going down in the finale so it's
possible season 5 could pick up with
Jonathan Pryce already being the High
Septon the show does have a history of
just brushing over minor characters and
since the previous High Septon the one
Tyrion picked wasn't featured a lot it's
possible that they could just deal with
them in an offhanded way it's possible
that they could just reference him in
past tense and even though the show is
changing a lot of things Jonathan Pryce
is character will probably have a lot of
the broad strokes from the high Sparrow
and book 4 because septons give up their
name whenever they're appointed High
Septon no one really knows his true
identity but I don't know there are a
lot of rumors and theories that he's
secretly another character so if you do
want to talk about that a little bit
just make sure you use spoiler tags in
the comments below
season 5 is the beginning of uncharted
territory in terms of book story so once
we get to season six it'll be a lot
easier for any of you that are only
watching the show to avoid spoilers even
though there are a lot of rumors for
November December 2015 winds of winter
release date but let's talk a little bit
about Jonathan prices character he's
actually gonna be really interesting I'm
really happy that they picked someone so
high profile but typically when I think
about him I still think Bond villain so
consider this a Bond villain is the
leader of the faith of the seven think
about what that might mean for his
character in season five and let's just
collectively choose to forget about
those awful GI Joe movies that he made
most of the big scenes that we've seen
so far for the faith of the seven
take place around Baylor except so
only interested to see if they build
that out more for season five the high
Sparrow is described as being very
unencumbered by a lot of the pomp and
ceremony that previous high septons had
so he doesn't wear crazy fancy robes or
the famous crowns the seven stars in it
I'm really interested to see how the
show chooses to introduce them just
because whenever a big character comes
in the show they usually give him some
sort of epic entrance I think Oberyn
Martell s was still one of my favorite
season for introductions at least for a
new character the high Sparrow is
probably gonna be one of the bigger
characters in season five but he's very
different from Oprah so I'm assuming
they're gonna give him an appropriately
pious entrance once season five starts
we can also start talking about some of
the big changes from the books of the
show because there's gonna be a lot
maybe in bonus videos maybe not in my
episode videos I don't want to start
doing that quite yet just because I know
a lot of you are still reading the books
what I would like to suggest it's just a
fun new type of bonus video is that we
all rewatched some old episodes together
and just do like a Twitter hashtag so we
can talk to each other while it's
happening it's just a lot easier to
collectively as a group watch old
episodes because new episodes always
there at different times around the
world so be sure to let me know in the
comments if you guys would be interested
in something like that and we can just
pick a day at a time that works for
everyone
and start looking at episodes to
re-watch for example we'd all just pick
an episode like Blackwater to rewatch
together at the same time and then we
just live tweet it with the same hashtag
then afterwards I just make a video from
all the favorite comments on it I will
still be doing regular bonus videos just
like normal I just thought that might be
a fun thing to do as a group just that
would feature some of your guys and
stuff and for any of those that don't
know my social links for like Twitter
Facebook and all that stuff or at the
top of my channel page or on the about
page I am planning a special video that
will explain what my schedule is gonna
be this fall like all the TV shows and
movies videos that I'm gonna be doing so
be sure to subscribe to get that I'll
try and post that by the middle of the
week feel free to suggest any TV shows
if there's something that you guys
really want to talk about that I'm not
doing yet the weekly giveaway in case
you guys don't know is really simple I
give away one Song of Ice and Fire book
per week all you have to do to enter is
be a subscriber and leave a comment on
this video and there won't be a Q&A for
this Game of Thrones video just because
Teen Wolf has a finale tonight and I
need to buy some furniture like it's
literally empty in my apartment right
now I'll still totally be answering
questions in the comments like normal
though right now you can click here to
learn more about the religions
Game of Thrones and you can click here
to learn more about the faceless men
thank you so much for watching I'll see
you guys tonight
high fives